hey guys how's it going
fortunately I know how it's going and
most of you guys know how it's going as
well and it's not so well in light of
recent events like this whole past week
has just been absolutely insane I don't
typically make videos on any of these
topics because I don't really I guess
like voicing my opinion so much I
sometimes like to keep quiet and I like
to keep things positive and uplifting
and I want my channel to be a place that
people can come and no matter what
you're gonna have fun entertaining
content whether you like it or whether
you don't like it but my god this week
has just been insane from the UCLA
shooting to one of our own people in the
community being gunned down by doing
something that she loved and then today
having woken up to this whole Orlando
nightclub shooting you know I don't like
making videos about it but I feel like I
don't want you guys to think that I'm
completely insensitive and it doesn't
affect me because I don't like to talk
about these things and I never want to
do things or make videos where it's
something that I'm doing just for views
because that is never anything that I
ever want to do I mean it I am even
debating making this video but I just
wanted you guys to just love each other
be happy be kind and do your part by
just being a good person and if there's
somebody who you think is going through
a tough time try to be there for that
person because you never know how you
could impact somebody else and if
there's ever a time where you're feeling
like you need help and you don't feel
right it's okay to ask for help it's
okay to go and talk to someone and have
a professional there to talk to because
that's their job that's what they're
there for there is nothing wrong with
doing that and the stigma with mental
health and the fact that some people
don't have access to the chance to talk
to people or have the medications that
need to be on is such
a huge issue as are the gun laws you
know I myself am a gun owner and if I
could give up all of that to ensure that
every person who should not own guns
would also give up their guns I mean I
would definitely do it in a second
because you know the problem too is also
being a responsible gun owner the people
that have these should not have them the
fact that I am able to walk into a store
and leave with a gun
it scares me knowing that people out
there who can also do this it blows my
mind like it actually blows my mind
you know I've look I don't even
something that I don't ever talk about I
don't like to address it because I do
not promote you know having and owning
and buying guns and those sorts of
things but the fact that it is that easy
and accessible to so many people and a
background check that's that doesn't
really tell you anything
perhaps a mental health evaluation
something you just should not be able to
leave a store and have a handgun in or
an assault rifle it it really does blow
my mind you know I I don't know what the
answer is there's no right answer
there's plenty of wrong answers but the
only thing that I can just really say is
just be nice be kind no one deserves any
of this and it I fear for the future of
events and meetups and conferences
because we love meeting you guys so much
I mean it's what keeps us going and the
fact that now our community is is going
to be in fear of that it's absolutely
terrifying and I just want you guys to
know that you're not alone everyone's
going through a lot right now and it's
okay to talk about it and I just
encourage you just to be kind in the
comments even things that I was tweeting
and reading today just reading responses
to people they're so hateful
they are so hateful fifty people died
and to read the things that people were
saying in response to news
apples I had to say off the internet
like I had I just had to go away it's
it's not good but in my quick video and
I don't want to have to have this be a
place of of sadness and I want this to
be a happy place and I do plan on
posting some fun videos this week
because it is III week and I just want
you to know that this is something that
I definitely do think about and it
breaks my heart and for me I just don't
really know what to even say other than
I love you guys and be well